My name is Martin Schutz. I'm a principal
research scientist
and the global lead for the Amazon Advanced
Solutions Lab,
and it is my great pleasure to be here
today with Romina Jalowettzky,
vice president and
research lead at JPMorgan Chase. So Romina
and I,
we want to take you on a little journey today
and show you how JPMorgan Chase
and AWS have collaborated together
on quantum R&D.
In our larger effort to advance
quantum research together.
Now if you've joined the session today, some of the
questions you may have is
what is quantum computing?
Short but profound.
What does quantum R&D look like
today in 2025?
And what are some of the use cases
in industry that we are exploring together?
So these are some of the questions that Romina and I
will try to answer with the following
agenda.
We're going to kick us off
with a broad overview of quantum
computing and how we embrace this
emerging technology at AWS.
We're gonna then double click on our
collaboration with JPMorgan Chase.
We're going to discuss some of the challenges
we faced,
some of the lessons learned.
And then describe the
solution that we came up with,
a hybrid quantum classical algorithm
that we tested with more than 200 cubits
on Amazon bracket.
We will share with you some of the research results
that we achieved together
and then we're going to conclude with a quick summary
and an outlook for
future research and next steps.
OK, so let's get started with the elephant
in the room. What is quantum
computing?
And maybe let's first say what it is not
so quantum computers are not
a classical computer that just runs
faster,
but really a new paradigm, a new
frontier
for computation that leverages
the somewhat intricate and bizarre
laws of quantum mechanics
to perform computations in
novel and improved ways.
So these quantum mechanical predictions, they might
seem bizarre to us because
we live in a macroscopic world,
but if you consider the microscopic world
of single electrons, single atoms,
single photons,
these quantum mechanical laws and predictions
have been tested and verified
again and again over the last few decades.
Boosting our confidence in this theory
up to the point that we are now ready to build
machines that exploit these fundamental
quantum mechanical
laws. And that
originally
Dates back to the early 80s
where Nobel Prize laureate
Richard Feynman
said Nature isn't classical,
damn it,
and if you want to make a simulation of nature,
you better make it quantum mechanical.
And bygoli, it's a wonderful problem
because it doesn't look so easy.
So what Feynman recognized
early on is that
the cost of simulating a
quantum system
grows exponentially with its number
of particles.
So if you consider
already a small quantum system
with 50 to 100 particles
cubits.
And if you want to emulate the system on
a classical computer,
Your memory requirements
are going to balloon. They're going to go through the roof,
and even for already for these small systems with
just 100 particles,
you're going to talk orders of magnitudes
that are
on the level of the number of particles in the
universe.
So let's try to unpack this.
At a fundamental level, all our
information, our classical information
is stored in binary bits
that we typically label as 01. It
doesn't matter if you take your cell phone, your laptop,
or a supercomputer.
Now if you take two of these classical
bits at any point in time,
these two bits
can be in one of four configurations
or 01
or 10
or 11.
However, if you take
the quantum equivalent.
Two quantum mechanical bits or in short qubits.
They can be
in 00 and
01 and 10
and 11.
At the same time,
that's perfectly fine by quantum physics because
of the superposition principle.
More formally, how we write this down, we write
in general.
A quantum mechanical wave function labeled
here as psi just because we physicists
like Greek symbols.
But if you, so if you start with a general quantum
mechanical wave function,
let's start with
one single qubit.
If you want to describe one single qubit on
a classical computer, you're going to have to
define two numbers,
A and B.
If you go one step further,
if you want to define a general 2 qubit
state on a classical computer, you will have
to track, define, and track 2
to 24 numbers A,
B, C, and D, because
this wave function can form a superposition
and can live in the space
of these 4 computational states
at the same time.
If you take 3 cubits, it's 238
numbers.
If you take 50 cubits, it's 10 million
billion complex amplitudes that you
have to track,
and that nicely exemplifies
this exponential wall
that you will hit if you try to replicate
or emulate a small quantum system with
just 50 cubits on a classical computer.
So taking this one step further, we then as a
community realized that quantum
computers can actually also solve some problems
with exponentially fewer resources
than classical computers.
And that means that really what we are
shooting here for is not just
a 2
quote unquote just 2x
speed up as you might achieve with say
your next generation GPU,
but really
a fundamentally different
2x speed up that will
allow us to solve problems
that we could not solve otherwise because they're
intractable for classical computers.
So where do we anticipate
these kind of speed ups?
We've categorized and identified here
4 major categories.
On the left
there's physics and chemistry and material
science, and these are intuitively
relatively easy to understand
because here at the end of the day
you have to solve inherently
quantum mechanical problems.
Take for example truck discovery.
You want to solve for the ground state
of a large molecule.
That's inherently a quantum mechanical
problem, and you will have to solve Schrodinger's equation.
There's arguably no better machine suited
to
complete this test than a quantum computer itself.
Material science
take our quest
to
build high temperature superconductors.
You will have to simulate
and understand the behavior
of many strongly correlated electrons.
Again, that's inherently a quantum mechanical
problem
that you better solve with a quantum machine.
Now What is maybe
even more striking is that later we
realized that quantum computers could actually
also solve
classical problems efficiently. And one of
the most famous examples is in cryptography,
where then in the 90s Peter Schor with
the Schor algorithm showed us
that you could actually crack.
In
classical encryption schemes such as
RSA,
the security of which rests on
the hardness
of factoring large numbers.
Something that cannot be done with classical
computers, even supercomputers, but where
showed us that this is
an easy task for a quantum computer.
Now taking this even one step further, we
then opened the aperture towards other
classical domains,
in particular optimization and machine
learning,
where quantum computers hold the promise
to solve problems such as resource
allocation
or portfolio optimization, and portfolio
optimization will be actually
the example use case that
Romina will then discuss in the second part
of this presentation.
OK, so this was kind of a
broad overview into quantum
computing and some of its
application areas.
So what does quantum R&D then look like
today? So
for
people in the field, scientists like Romina
and me,
the North Star is to lay
the groundwork
for future production workloads
typically
through hybrid quantum classical
workflows.
Now to get there we typically work backwards
by first identifying target
use cases
that on the one hand
are computationally hard.
And are
interesting to your business.
Once we have identified such a use case,
we then research
new quantum algorithms and
we were going to benchmark them against
the state of the art classical algorithms.
With that, develop new IP and
push the boundaries in our effort
to ultimately lay the groundwork
for the quantum future.
Now another twist to this is
our effort in bringing
this technology
from a niche technology today towards
broad adoption in the future.
So how do we think we can go about this
and achieve that?
Well, so we think we have to first research quantum
devices.
We have to research and benchmark quantum
algorithms.
Once we then take quantum
algorithms and quantum devices together, we
can solve some first scientific
use cases,
but ultimately again, the North Star
is to solve industry relevant
problems with broad application
and in doing so in our
journey as a community,
we want to switch gears from
studying the hammer.
Towards using the hammer.
Now to help you
on this journey towards using this hammer.
We offer
a suite of tools and offerings. One of them
is Amazon Bracket,
our quantum computing service on
AWS, which provides one consistent
experience no matter what your workload might
look like. So this could be simple
experimentations. This could be.
Deep research all the
way to future
larger scales in the future all
through one consistent experience where we
provide access
to different quantum hardware providers,
third party quantum computers, as well
as our own quantum hardware in the fullness
of time. Now
if you access Amazon bracket
today, already today,
you will
find a broad portfolio of quantum
devices
that features.
Quantum computers based on trapped ions
from INQ and AQT.
Two superconducting devices
from Regetti and IQM,
all of them are accessible
and programmable through the standard quantum
circuit paradigm.
But we also offer access
to Qerra's Aquila device
which already today comes with 256
cubits,
and this one is programmed
through the paradigm of analog
Hamiltonian simulation
which is geared towards solving
optimization workloads.
Another offering how we
want to help you on your quantum journey
is the Amazon Advanced Solutions Lab.
That's a team of scientists that I lead.
We engage in deep
custom R&D engagements
that are tailored towards your unique business
challenges.
We typically follow a two-pronged approach.
On the one hand, we research and
develop
novel quantum algorithms.
And at the same time we deliver business
value today with state of the art
classical algorithms, often quantum
inspired or physics inspired algorithms
that adopt ideas and principles
from quantum mechanics but can run already
today on classical compute.
Through that
we develop
IP
and know-how and help you prepare
for the quantum future.
And I think the most important message and outcome
is with that we
provide. Actionable outcomes
without the hype.
Such that you can understand if and when
quantum will impact your business
and inform your business stakeholders
with
target use cases,
and I think one beautiful example is
the work that we did with JPMorgan
Chase and now Romina will show you
and walk you through our collaboration.
Thank you Martin.
Hello everyone, good afternoon.
Uh, my name is Romina Shaloetzki.
Uh, and it's my pleasure,
uh, being here today, uh, to
share with you all how at JPMorgan
Chase,
uh, we have been collaborating with AWS.
So we are the Global Technology applied
research team at JPMorgan Chase.
We conduct an applied
research focused on the frontier
technologies
to transform scientific findings
into business value.
To do this, we work on 4 areas.
We assess the impact of novel
technologies
on the firm and for our customers.
We perform research driven
by use cases
to enhance client experiences
and optimize business processes.
We offer competitive advantage
via research-driven solutions.
And we execute proof of concept
initiatives to validate and demonstrate
initiative.
Our initiatives are and innovative
solutions.
Finance is rich in computationally
hard problems in optimization.
Actually optimization is ubiquitous
in our industry.
We can find this type of problems
in different areas in the financial
industry, uh, just a few of them
are portfolio selection and optimization,
pricing and hedging of options,
risk management, and also
asset
and liability management.
So as you can see, optimization
er is all over the place
er in finance.
And just to give you an idea of
one of these problems that
can be a potential use case for
quantum computing,
er, this is a portfolio selection
problem. So
here we consider a universe of assets.
These assets can be stocks,
derivatives, different types of instruments.
And we also consider the correlation
between these assets
and the idea here is that we would like to find
the largest set of uncorrelated
assets.
One way of visualizing this
is by.
Putting each of these assets, let's say A,
B and C, and all of them,
they're in the graph,
so you can see each node represents
one of these assets.
Then we have the edges between them
which represent the correlation that
we have.
So for example in this case, A is
correlated with D,
but A is not correlated, for example
with the asset E.
And now we would like to find the largest
set of uncorrelated assets.
In this case, you can see them uh
color in purple,
so we will have A, C, and
G. And you can see that these
nodes are not connected with an edge.
By doing this, we can find the set
of uncorrelated assets and
this could be a very diversified
er strategy
for for then allocate
capital.
In principle, this problem we
can have 228 solutions,
so if you would like to try out all possible combinations.
So this is 11 problem.
And actually we have seen that this problem can
become very hard.
So let me try to explain a
little bit what we mean with heart and what is the
challenge that we see in optimization
in finance.
So for example here you can see the runtime
in the Y axis
and in the X axis the problem harness.
And what we see is that the run
time can scale exponentially
with how hard the problem is.
One notion of hardness is the size,
so let's say that we consider a universe
with 100 assets.
We will see that all the possible combinations
that we can have is 1030.
This is 10 followed by 30
zeros.
Now increase a little bit more our universe
and now let's say that we have 1000
assets.
Now we will have 10
to 301 possible combinations if we
would like to do the brute force and go
over each possible combination.
So now remember that this is 10 followed by
301 zeros.
So we can see in this example how
exponentially the run time
can increase.
So actually we are very interested in that
side where we identify problems
that are very hard for classical
computers
are actually those type of problems
that we can
try to find some potential use
cases for quantum.
Actually this problem of portfolio
selection
can be framed as a more general
problem which is known as a maximum
independent set.
This is a problem that has been studied
widely in in the computer science
uh community
and the idea here is that we
are going to consider a graph of
this type
and we can do this more generally
instead of thinking about assets as each
node, we are just going to think
about nodes and edges.
And the idea here is to find the maximum
independent set.
This is the set of nodes that are not
correlating between each other
and this is the maximum size that we
can get.
This problem has applications
in different domains
such as map labeling,
network design,
vehicle routing,
and as we commented before, in quantitative
finance with a portfolio selection
problem.
So now let me comment a little bit on on
the situation in quantum computing
when we started our collaboration
with AWS.
So by the time there was an empirical
demonstration
of a quantum speed up, uh,
published in the journal Science
by Evarietal.
And the idea in the paper is
that the authors
showed an experiment, some experiments
with up to 289 cubits
for the maximum independent set problem,
which is a problem that we just discussed.
In the paper, they show some
quantum speed up
er in the form as you can see there uh
in the plot
where in terms of success rate,
which the larger the better, it means
that the algorithm can run
faster.
We see that with quantum we
get that curve that is over the classical.
So in purple we have the performance with
quantum.
In blue er with classical
and we can see this performance boost
that we can get with a quantum
computer. So
this was a very good motivation
for a collaboration between JPMorgan Chase
and AWS at the time.
And also very much motivated by this problem
of the maximum independence set
that as we have seen uh the portfolio
selection problem can be framed in this
way. So
through our collaboration,
we have published 4 scholarly
papers.
There you can find the links for for
the archive version of them
and we have also released
the code that we developed for
these works and that also you can find
them in the papers.
And through our quantum R&D
journey, uh, we have managed
to develop a suite of tools
for solving large and hard
problems
on today's quantum computers.
it. Today,
together with Martin, we, we would like to focus
on the very last work
that that we we have published.
So let's take a look er into this
work. So here
we introduced a hybrid
algorithm.
That uses both classical and quantum
computers.
We call this algorithm Q redumi,
Q for quantum,
R for reduction,
and MIS for the maximum independent
set problem.
And as you can see there, we are going to
use both the classical and the quantum
computer because at the end of the day
we want to get the best out
of these two
computational paradigms.
And you can see we have the circle
there because this is a recursive algorithm
where we are going to call both the
classical and the quantum computer.
So let's take a look to what they are
going to do on the classical computer.
Here, the idea is to perform an
exact reduction.
So the idea is that we are going to try
to reduce the problem.
So we are going to start with a graph
as we discussed before, where each node can
represent an asset
and it is that we are going to reduce it.
And to do this,
we take into account a basic
property of the maximum independent
set, which is that any click
can host at most one selected
node. In
this case, the idea of a clique
is a group of notes
that they they are connected between each other.
So for example,
here you can see that 1011 and 12,
they are connected between each other.
So that's uh one example of a clique.
And also the idea is that we are going
to reduce the problem
by removing what we call exposed
corner nodes.
Those are the ones that you see there in blue.
So for example you can see that
the node 2 is connected with
33 is part of a click
with also 476,
and 5.
But you can see that node there looks like
exposed because it's not connected with
anything else.
So that's one example of exposed node
and also the idea is that we are going to do this
for the whole graph,
so we're going to identify these
exposed corner nodes.
Now we are going to play a sort of
game that we refer as the Pac-Man.
So the idea is that we are going to start going
over the graph and we are going to
start removing some of these nodes
using the Pac-Man.
So for example here we are going to start with
the node one,
as you can see here the node one is
isolated.
So trivially this node can be part
of our solution because it's not
connected with anything.
In other words, it's not correlated with
any other assets.
So we are going to keep it as part of our solution,
so we remove it.
Now we are going to take a look to the node
2 as we said that's an exposed
quarter node
we are going to keep it in our solution
but we're going also to remove 3
because remember that we don't want
two nodes that have an edge
together. So we remove it,
we come here, we do the same with
8 and 6,
it goes away.
We do the same now with 9 and
10. Here
again we take 11
and we also remove 12.
Now 13
again this node is isolated
so we're going to keep it for a solution.
And now we reach here a click,
and the idea here is that we can select
any of these 3 notes.
In this case we're going to select 4.
And you can see in this example
that by playing
with the Pac-Man,
we have managed to solve the problem.
So you can see now all these nodes that
are in blue,
these are going to be part of our
solution.
You can see that they are not connected with an edge
and this is the largest set of
uncorrelated
assets.
In this case, we managed to do it 100%,
the reduction,
so you can see it's a very
powerful technique.
But in the most general case,
maybe if it's more complex a problem,
it's not going to be 100%.
We have performed
er many experiments
with different networks, different
graphs of this form,
er you can see them there.
These are some networks that are
used in social sciences.
Uh, and I would like to draw your attention
to the very last one, the PubMed.
This is a network where each
node represents a publication,
and the edges between them are
the citations that these publications,
uh, have between them.
You can see that this network is
quite large. It has
around 19,000
nodes.
We applied this reduction, this
Pac-Man,
and we managed to get now a graph
uh that we call a kernel with
16 nodes.
And you can see that we managed to do this
in less than a second. So
this is around 600
milliseconds.
So you can see that this technique is is very
powerful.
So now let's see it in action for a
problem that is of our interest.
We are going to have a graph like this.
Remember that each of these nodes
can represent an asset in the market,
the edge is the correlation.
We take this graph,
we put it inside a classical computer,
and we are going to play with the Pac-Man this
reduction.
The Pacman starts going over
the graph,
is going to take some of these notes
and are going to be put in the basket
of selected notes
and it's also going to remove some
of them in blue and it's going to go
to the removed basket.
We do this all over the graph
and there is one point that the Pac-man
stops
and it cannot get inside.
So in this case, we managed to reduce
the problem.
By a 73%.
But now there is a point where there is
no more exposed corner notes
for the Pac-Man to continue
going in.
And this is what we call the kernel.
In other words, this is the hardest part
of the graph
where actually now this Pac-Man cannot
go in. And
now the question is, OK, we have managed to identify
the hardest part of this problem
now how can we solve it?
For this, we are going to use the quantum
computer. Intuitively
the idea is that instead of using
the whole graph and inputting
everything into the quantum hardware,
now we are going to focus on the hardest
part of this problem.
So let's see how we use a quantum
computer. The
idea that we leverage in this work
is that quantum computers
are probabilistic sampling
machines.
So let us show you what
does it mean.
So the idea is that we are going to take our kernel
that it looks like that,
we're going to put it inside a quantum
computer and now the question is
what do we get out of it?
Let's consider a graph that is smaller,
so maybe it's
uh it's easier to understand.
So the idea is that we are going to consider here
only those four notes.
And let's see what happens. We put it inside
the quantum computer
and let's see the output.
The idea is that we are going to execute
the quantum program a couple of times,
let's say 500 times.
This is what we typically refer as quantum
shots.
Every time that we run we measure
and with that we construct that histogram
that you see there.
In the X axis we have
an identification of the node,
so you can see there 123
and 4. Each of them refers
to a node.
And what we're going to do, we are going to
report how many times we see these
notes
appearing in our solutions.
So for example, here, let's say
that the node one
appears only 10 times.
So out of the 500 times
that we measure,
we only see that the node one appears
only in 10 of them.
In contrast, the note 3
appears in 490 times.
So the idea here is that if we see
the node 3 appearing so
much across our measurements,
it seems like it has high likelihood
for the selection.
So the idea is that we are going to
to keep this node as part of our
solution. In this
idea that we want to identify assets
that are uncorrelated, this could
be a potential asset that we would like to
have in our solution.
So now let's put together all the
different er ingredients that we
discussed.
So the idea is that we start with a graph.
We have our baskets empty, the ones
that we're going to put the notes to select
and the ones to remove.
er here we may consider a market
graph.
Now we apply a reduction
this Pac-Man.
We start putting some of the notes in
their respective baskets and we reach
the kernel, that great part that you
see there. Now we take
the kernel, we put it into the quantum
computer and in this case we identified
the pink node, the dark pink node
as one of being with high likelihood
of being part of our solution.
So we put it in the baskets of selected
and we remove it together with the neighbors
in the light pink.
Because we don't want to keep notes that that are
connected.
Then we go back to a classical computer
and we try again.
Can now the Pac-Man solve the problem
to optimality?
And in this case, yes, it managed to
do it. So in this case
we managed to solve the problem.
And the idea is the following
classical reduction
together with a quantum computer
as a sampling machine
is a powerful technique to solve
the MIS problem
and one example of this problem is a
portfolio selection.
So now we would like to share with you some of
the results.
So as you have seen, this
is the algorithm
and we have performed uh
some experiments using a
real quantum hardware
er of course here with the.
With our algorithm, we utilize
both the classical and the quantum
computer. For
our experiments we leverage the Aquila
machine which is available by
QEra
and we access it through
Amazon bracket.
And the idea here in this graph is that
we are going to compare our algorithm
Qreumis
uh which is uh uh in blue.
We are going to compare it with quantum annealing.
So quantum annealing is a
standard algorithm that that we can run
on this type of devices.
Uh, era,
uh, is a device that is, well,
a cuera's Aquila device,
er, is based on river atoms.
So with this type of architecture, we
can run the quantum annealing
algorithm.
And the idea here is that we are going to use
our framework, the QRomis algorithm,
and we are going to power it with
quantum annealing.
So here we compare the two
results, the two, the two algorithms.
In the X axis we have
the problem hardness
as we commented before,
one notion of hardness could be the size
of a problem.
Let's say in this example of portfolio
selection could be how many
assets we have in our universe,
but also there are some other metrics that we
can use
to ident to understand how hard is a
problem. And
in the Y axis we have the success
probability.
The success probability,
as we said before,
the larger the better.
This is a number between 0 and 1,
so the closer to 1, the better.
It means that the algorithm is going
to run
faster.
So here we can see in red
quantum annealing. This is the standard
quantum algorithm.
And we see that if the problem is not
that hard at the very beginning of of
the plot,
we see that in some cases we
get a quite good
success probability.
But as this problem becomes harder
and harder,
we start to see that exponential
decay. It's
such that at one point at the
very end, you can see that the
success probability is 0.
That means that now we cannot
get the optimal solution.
We may be able to get a close
to optimal solution,
but actually the probability of measuring
the optimal solution for a problem
is zero.
In contrast, you can see in blue
the performance of cute redomness.
This performance is very much concentrated
around one
you can see that for different problem
harness is very much concentrated
there er in one.
At the very end of the graph,
now that we are considering
problems that are harder and harder,
we see a small decay,
but overall the performance of
the algorithm
is over
89%.
So the main idea here is that we
managed
to get a performance boost in
comparison to quantum annealing.
Um, as we said, we have run
this on the real, uh,
hardware, on the real quantum device,
uh, through, uh, Amazon bracket.
Uh, and we have managed to go to a very
large size and also you can see
that we can see a different values
of problem harness.
Um
So yes, so here we managed
to to overcome this suppression
that that as we said is very limiting
because at some point we're not going
to be able to get the optimal
while with Q resumes uh
in most of the cases we managed
to get uh the optimal solution
with some
success probability.
With that, er, I would like to, to hand
in uh to Martin for the summary
er and outlook.
OK, uh,
thank, thank you, thank you, Mina, for this, um.
Nice,
nice overview of our collaboration and
some of the results that we
achieved together, um.
Over
the course of two years culminating
in
4 publications and this hybrid
classical algorithm that we refer to as
Qanomus, so
we try to take you on a journey. This has
been our quantum R&D journey
through this collaboration
we have developed
several methods. The key insight
was that we
um. Want to exploit some of
the state of the art classical techniques
where they are really the best at and
exploit them as much as possible
such that eventually
we can have the quantum computer
focus on what is really the hard
core or the hard kernel of the problem.
And for that we developed this
hybrid quantum classical algorithm
which is a general purpose solver
for the maximum independent set problem, and
we showed you how this can find
applications, in particular
in portfolio selection.
In our paper we actually show how this can
be part of a larger pipeline
for portfolio optimization where you then
distribute your budget
across these diversified
selected assets.
Um
The results that we achieved
are in particular
our experiments
with over 200 qubits.
They were all executed
through the cloud on AWS
on Amazon Bracket.
And in the future we're looking to
test
this algorithm on alternative
hardware platforms.
This algorithm, the concept per se,
is actually hardware agnostic.
Here we focused on a device
based on Rudberg atoms,
but you could essentially plug and
play. And
try your best, try your luck with say
trapped ions or superconducting qubits
and then really
compare them head to head for
one single pane
of glass.
Another step how we want to take this forward
is obviously look for
other applications besides portfolio
selection because we think this is actually a pretty
broad, powerful.
Framework that combines the
best of two worlds, the classical state of
the art reduction algorithms,
and the quantum samplers.
And with that
we'd like to thank you
for listening. Thanks for coming,
and a quick reminder,
we please complete the session survey
on the app. Thank you very much.